[Music]
on this wednesday night canada's key
interest rate keeps climbing
it reflects very unusual economic
circumstances the biggest hike in more
than two decades with food prices set to
soar
video of the yuvaldi school shooting
what police did and did not do plus
backlash to the leaked footage it's
going to be in our social media forever
aiming to move the needle on covet
vaccine boosters differing
recommendations for different people and
remember new coke or colgate lasagna
innovation creates what what the future
will be welcome to the museum of failure
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight mithu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
with inflation in this country at a
39-year high there were signals this was
coming but today the bank of canada
still surprised most forecasters with
the largest hike to its key interest
rate in nearly 25 years it's gone up a
full percentage point to 2.5 percent
it's the biggest increase since august
of 1998 and the fourth since march of
this year the change will have an
immediate impact on all kinds of debt
including variable rate mortgages ann
gaviola has more on what every household
needs to know about the rate hike and
its impact in our top story tonight
desperate times call for desperate
measures an increase of this magnitude
in one meeting is very unusual
it reflects very unusual economic
circumstances it's been a big shock and
a big change for me personally the
latest hike means 400 more in monthly
mortgage payments compared to what was
needed in january for this 30 year old
toronto resident who got into the
housing market during the pandemic she's
cutting back where she can dining out
groceries as well is a big line item for
me to see where i can cut back and maybe
look for more savings
aside from that like non-essential
travel for a typical variable rate
mortgage of 2.7 on a home priced at the
national average of 711 000
the monthly mortgage payment of more
than 2800 increases to more than 3 100
a difference of nearly 325 extra per
month
the central bank says steep successive
rate hikes are putting the squeeze on
variable rate mortgages which were
wildly popular during the pandemic
anyone with a variable rate
has been stress tested at five and a
quarter percent so i'm confident that
most households
will be able to still make their
mortgage payments interest rates have
already cooled the housing market the
end goal is taming the overall soaring
cost of living by reducing economic
demand and discouraging people and
businesses from taking on more debt we
are increasing our policy rate quickly
to prevent high inflation from becoming
entrenched
if it does it will be more painful for
the economy and for canadians to get
inflation back down the bank says the
risk of not tackling inflation
forcefully now is too great but
recessions have historically followed
aggressive rate hikes to combat high
inflation the bank of canada has a very
bad record for the so-called soft
landing where they get inflation back
down to their target of two percent
but they avoid a recession
the success rate in the last 60 years in
canada is zero percent the next central
bank rate decision is in early september
when the economic picture may look very
different ann gaviola global news
toronto
canadians are already feeling the pinch
of higher prices on just about
everything and the cost of groceries
will keep climbing the global food
supply is being impacted by weather
labor and geopolitics like russia's
invasion of ukraine and while the
official numbers are expected next week
it's clear canadians are paying more
than they have in decades mike trolley
has more
toronto's kensington market is known for
its relaxed vibe it's where we met
sebastian churio who is the grocery
buyer for supernatural market has seen a
dramatic increase in messages from
suppliers notifying him of price hikes
wow that's a lot of emails
that's a lot of emails and that's making
it increasingly difficult to stay chill
i have my phone with
notifications off because it's it it
produces
anxiety you start to feel anxious
related if i keep this with me i'll go
crazy
at the end of the day he says there's no
getting around it groceries will keep
getting more expensive the price of milk
for one has gone up 25 since january for
myself i would probably pay 400 a month
now i'm going to 700 a month for the
family yes that much it has increased
food inflation which measures how much
more consumers are paying compared to a
year ago is at 10.4 percent in the u.s
the highest it's been in 40 years in may
canada was at 9.7 percent which is
expected to rise when new numbers are
released next week but the sweet spot
for food inflation in my view is
anywhere between 1.5 to 2.5 percent so
as you can imagine at nine point seven
percent were very far off consumers it
should come as no surprise aren't happy
about it with many accusing corporations
of profiteering actually 68 percent of
canadians actually believe that
reflation exists is that prices are
inflated
not because of costs just because
companies are trying to make more money
but charlotte boss says the reality is
the big three sobes metro in loblaws
have thin margins revenues may have been
higher during the pandemic but profit
margins remain steady between two and
four percent
that will do little to soften the blow
of grocery bills that are getting harder
for canadian families to stomach
mike girlie global news toronto
new numbers from statistics canada show
how the rising cost of pretty much
everything is changing the way canadians
are living the data from the 2021 census
shows fewer people are living in what
used to be the norm traditional single
family homes nearly one million
households are now comprised of multiple
generations of the same family or
multiple families or a family with
additional people living with them often
a renter 4.4 million canadians are now
living alone the highest share on record
the fastest growing housing setup is
roommates unrelated people living
together to share the high cost of
housing with the number of roommate
households growing by 54 percent from
2001 to 20-21
the omicron ba-5 sub-variant is driving
coveted 19's seventh wave accelerating
case counts putting even more pressure
on hospitals and emergency rooms right
as summer travel heats up today
newfoundland and labrador said people
age 50 and over will be able to get a
second booster in one week and ontario
opened up its eligibility for a fourth
dose while my call for arms remains the
loudest for the most vulnerable in our
communities we've made the decision to
expand the eligibility for second
boosters
to include ontarians aged from 18 to 59
years of age
starting tomorrow ontarians age 18 to 59
who've had their first booster at least
five months ago or at least three months
after a coveted 19 infection can get a
second booster shot almost 90 percent of
booster shots in ontario were
administered five or more months ago
while booster effectiveness starts to
wane after four months
there is a patchwork of provincial
recommendations and timelines but as
jamie maraca reports the bottom line is
if you are high risk the advice is to go
and get your next dose as soon as you
can
long lines to get a covet 19 vaccine are
a thing of the past now it's a struggle
to get people on board with boosters
with just over half of eligible
canadians having received their third
dose there's no question about it
between the second shot and the third
one that's where the rubber hits the
road research suggests kovid's latest
omicron mutations ba 4 and 5 are four
times more resistant to vaccine
antibodies compared to their predecessor
ba2 and while pharmaceutical companies
such as moderna and pfizer are working
on formulas to target those strains
experts still encourage getting a third
shot with the current mrna vaccine the
main benefit is just from boosting so
boosting jacks up the antibodies which
protects the against all of the variants
including ba-5 the federal government
recommends a booster nine months post
your last shot but it isn't a hard and
fast rule some provinces now say five
months is long enough and if you are
young and healthy and are hoping for a
fourth dose experts say the best defense
is one that is timed you want your
highest protection from the vaccine
which is within the first few months
after you get a dose
to be at a time when virus is highest
over the age of 50 living in long-term
care or immunocompromised doctors
suggest booking a booster now
and if you've just had covid three
months is how long you should wait to
get another shot but it doesn't mean
you're in the clear to get infected with
ba1 you're well protected against pa1
except we don't have any ba1 anymore
right now you have to worry about ba5
canadian scientists are tracking even
newer strains and while they can't be
certain what covit has in store vaccines
they say are likely to play a role in
our protection plan every year jamie
marrocker global news toronto
one man has been charged in the alleged
hack of aaron o'toole's conservative
leadership campaign two years ago the
rcmp have charged dionne away with one
count of mischief under the section of
the criminal code dealing with
obstructing or interfering with the
lawful use of computer data aaron
o'toole's office had no comment but at
the time blamed peter mckay's campaign
for the breach mckay tells global news
he has no personal knowledge of the
matter but understands hawaii was
contracted by a company that had a
contract with his campaign mckay says
his team would have no way of vetting
hawaii he's scheduled to appear in court
in august
thanks to a new court challenge we may
learn more about the canadian
government's decision to exempt the
return of pipeline turbines from our
country's sanctions against russia
gazprom the russian state-owned energy
company says the turbines are essential
to the operation of the nord stream
pipeline but the ukrainian world
congress is casting doubt on those
claims as abigail beeman reports the
prime minister is now defending the move
as a difficult but necessary decision
addressing turbine tension for the first
time the prime minister didn't speak to
new legal action taken by the ukrainian
world congress against the government
but he did defend his choice those
sanctions are aimed not at our allies
but at putin and his cronies and that's
exactly
why we took this difficult decision
to be there for our allies we're very
grateful to canada germany's ambassador
to canada tells global news it wasn't an
ask taken lightly and acknowledges
there's no guarantee russia won't just
turn off the taps anyway we don't know
we simply do not know and that's
i think a very important point wednesday
morning russian state-owned gazprom
tweeted it had no documents showing
siemens could get the turbine out of
canada we do not want to give russia and
putin the kind of excuse to say oh you
brought it upon yourself that we will
not honor our obligation to deliver gas
anymore because you do not deliver the
turbine the new legal challenge against
the canadian government calls russia's
claim to need that turbine a
disingenuous ploy the application for
judicial review
challenges the reasonableness of the
minister's
decision to
allow for the exemption
we really should be shaken by that
reaction oral brawn says zolensky's
fierce rebuke of canada is evidence of
enormous frustration in reaction to a
precedent-setting move this is a very
unfortunate crack
in what should have been a unified
system of keeping pressure up on russia
russia tested us
and we failed a complicated situation
with diplomacy energy and war all on the
line
abigail beeman global news ottawa
new outrage in uvalde texas tonight
coming up the uproar over a video of the
school shooting leaked
newly released surveillance video from
inside a texas elementary school seems
to puncture the myth that a good guy
with a gun is the best response to a
mass shooting as jackson proskow reports
the video shows heavily armed police
officers milling in the hallways of robb
elementary school while 19 children and
two teachers were being massacred and a
warning the sights and sounds in this
story are disturbing
the leaked video shows the moment the
gunman enters robb elementary seconds
later a child comes around the corner
sees the gun
and then runs as gunshots echo through
the hallways less than three minutes
later the first police officers arrive
almost immediately they're pushed back
by more heavy gunfire for the next 20
minutes heavily armed officers arrive
and assemble in the hallway but they
never try to enter the classroom one
officer even stops to sanitize his hands
and lean against a wall another 20
agonizing minutes pass as children
inside the classroom call 911 begging
for help before officers finally
breached the classroom door and killed
the shooter whoever leaked that video i
pray that you never never have to deal
with what all the parents the
grandparents the siblings the aunts the
uncles the cousins are dealing with the
stunning public leak of the recording
has forced families of the victims to
relive the horror of that day
a glimpse into the horrific final
moments of 19 children and two teachers
the way that video was released today is
one of the most chicken things i've ever
seen the mayor of uvalde lashed out at
the league and promptly faced backlash
at a public meeting over his police
department's response that day it's like
ptsd you see them and you just want to
go after them you know
anger rage they're just cowards
you need to resign
the video does not bring closure or
answers about whether quicker action
could have saved lives it only offers a
horrific record of a modern american
tragedy jackson prosko global news
washington
sri lanka's state of emergency ahead the
protest political chaos and a country in
crisis
[Music]
you're watching global national
[Music]
to the growing chaos in sri lanka
sparked by a spiraling economic meltdown
a curfew and state of emergency has been
declared after the country's president
fled early this morning while protesters
have now occupied the presidential
palace and government offices as crystal
gmancing reports sri lankans are pushing
back against skyrocketing fuel and food
prices and the calling for more leaders
to step aside
armed with grievances over their
inability to afford food for their
families or purchase fuel
demonstrators hit another government
building in the sri lankan capitol
the army and police used tear gas and
water cannons to keep people out of the
prime minister's office but those
tactics failed these were not the usual
protesters sri lanka sees these were
middle class people
who just filled the brunt of it and felt
something needed to be done
economic unrest plagues the island
nation in the indian ocean
the people blame the government for the
mismanagement and as citizens occupy and
roam offices of the prime minister and
the president they say the opulence is
infuriating
this is a great opportunity for people
to see these buildings it is only now
they realize the luxurious lives they
have paid with tax money
for the first time in the country's
history the president is in exile
gotabaya rajapaksa fled on a military
plane with his wife as calls for his
resignation grew louder the prime
minister now in charge declared a state
of emergency and imposed a curfew many
thought
he told the nation in crisis they must
defeat this fascist threat
demonstrations however are unlikely to
stop until new elections are held
without political stability we're not
going to be able to address the economic
crisis and what is likely to be a
humanitarian crisis very soon human
rights lawyer bhavani von seka says with
so many people suffering there are fears
the mostly peaceful demonstrations
could turn violent
crystal gomanson global news
london
during a raucous sitting of the u.k
house of commons outgoing prime minister
boris johnson said he's leaving with his
head held high
make your mind up either shut up and get
out
the speaker ordered several lawmakers
from the chamber as the weekly prime
minister's question session got underway
conservative lawmakers also narrowed the
field of candidates looking to succeed
johnson as pm to six with former finance
minister rishi sunak topping the first
round of voting the new leader will be
named on september 5th
infamous failures next inside the museum
dedicated to nothing but mega mistakes
so here is bobby jane
hello barbie jane
toymaker mattel has unveiled a jane
goodall barbie as part of its inspiring
women series the doll wearing khaki
shorts and binoculars and holding a
notebook is a nod to goodall's
conservation efforts as a primatologist
and groundbreaking chimpanzee research
girls don't want just to be film stars
and things like that but many of them
like me want to be out in nature
studying animals
the 88 year old first started her
research in 1960. she says this new
barbie fulfills a lifelong wish
on the road to success failure is
inevitable and throughout history there
have been some doozies so many in fact
there is a museum in sweden dedicated to
some of the world's most famous flubs
and now that exhibit has come to canada
so if you're in calgary this summer you
can check out some of humanity's
greatest innovation flops but as heather
urex west explains it's not about
highlighting failure it's about learning
and inspiring
call it the best of the worst the
products that tried to innovate but fell
flat new coke anyone innovation creates
what what the future will be
and as part of that creation process
naturally there will be times where
there's going to be failure fascinated
with flops swedish curator samuel west
decided to begin this collection and the
museum of failure was born the traveling
exhibit has now been all over the world
with its first canadian stop here in
calgary remember these lawn darts so
dangerous they were eventually banned or
this doll from 1965.
baby no name was meant to teach kids
compassion but terrified them instead a
lot of these innovations push technology
to its limits before actually
being properly tested and properly
marketed some failures cost money and
some became giant
messes olestra was a widely marketed fat
substitute that caused a lot of
i would call it gastrointestinal issues
before stand-up or treadmill desks
became popular consumers could purchase
this chair to work their core
for some reason though
it never caught on
but as henry ford said the only real
mistake is the one from which we learn
nothing and companies like apple have
clearly overcome missteps along the way
oh for sure i mean products that fail
usually you can get better products out
of it it's a learning experience so i'm
a teacher so i think you know it's
something that i encourage my students
and my kids to do all the time and in
this building full of blunders big and
small that's kind of the point the road
to success is paved in failure one
colgate lasagna or goopy orbits soda at
a time heather urex west global news
calgary
you never know unless you try and that
is global national for this wednesday
night i'm nitu garcia tonight's your
canada is king's throne peak overlooking
kathleen lake and yukon's kluwani
national park thanks for watching i'll
see you again tomorrow good night